hey guys what's up vlog university is
going on the road well i'm going on the
road and since vlog university is my
show it's coming with me right
so most of you guys probably are already
aware of the show called escape routes
that's airing every saturday on nbc at 8
00 p.m eastern and i'm gonna be the
online host for the show so here's the
deal this is pretty awesome because not
only are you guys gonna be submitting
homework assignments to me but you can
submit your homework assignments for
show and tell on escape routes so
they're giving me the challenges i'm
giving them to you guys you can use them
as vlog university homework assignments
and you can also submit them to escape
routes to win fun cool prizes which is
pretty sweet because i don't actually
give you guys prizes to do your homework
so your homework assignment slash show
and tell is hands-free create a video of
you guys doing something crazy something
fun but hands-free
i have no idea what any of this means i
have no idea either it's crazy talk
the important thing though is to do it
hands-free
it's not a challenge so you guys have to
submit a video hands-free it's really
hot in here it better be something good
too nothing dirty awesome nothing bad
yeah nothing's don't be sick yeah okay
oh man it's really warm in there
use your imagination keep it clean keep
it pg or maybe even g for my sake
because i'm gonna have to watch these
videos
in the last episode of vlog university
your homework assignment was cooking and
let me tell you what some of you people
seriously should not be in the kitchen
get those ready on your counter that you
just bleached down and has lots of
chemicals grab it with your hand
stick some on your bread that's yummy
that's really good don't get scared
everyone see the popcorn it's popping
okay
and then there's some of you guys who i
would probably love to hire as a
personal chef
make sure you wash your hands
you come to my house cook for me please
thank you guys so much for watching this
episode of vlog university i will see
you guys in a different city every
single week for the next month and a
half and i'm so excited because i get to
take you guys with me it's gonna be so
much fun because every saturday after
the actual show escape routes arizona
nbc i'm gonna be hosting a really cool
fun live chat with you with me with the
contestants where we can talk about what
actually happened on the show and you
guys can actually tweet me questions i
say actually way too much way too much
let's work on that actually i wanted to
show you guys this car because all of
the contestants are driving around in
these sweet cars that are tricked out
with crazy microphones which i actually
hope is not live streaming right now
because i look like a crazy person
sitting in this car talking to a camera
okay i'm gonna show you guys what you
look like right now so this is you guys
right here
i have my laptop here i'm editing and so
this is the camera that
live streams to the internet so they
said that this camera right here there's
something like in the back that also
while it's live streaming it's actually
capturing all of this footage i honestly
can't even tell you what it is
first aid kit behave
this is
it's freaking crazy what if i just took
this car and drove somewhere bye-bye
sorry red team i just stole your car
anyway i'm gonna go because i could
seriously talk to you guys forever this
past week was so much fun i went to
playlist live i got to see you guys
okay so i forced my sister to come here
too jenna
yeah see you guys on the road different
city every week
vlog university escape routes it's it's
like we're best friends now okay i'm
gonna go
bye